釣り続け終わった英語90点
すごい今日肇社長です皆さんこれ知ってますでしょうかよく見るんですけども嘘発見器
というものがありますこれ実は使ったことないんですけどなんかあれですよね当てれば
たおいてもうゴボウみたいですけど
構成が雑だな嘘発見器の上に手を置いてなく質問されますよそれが嘘だったらこんな
髪の毛立つ編みだけこんなになる
ような流石にここまではならないでしょ多分思ってますね自らこれぐらい中ビリビリッ
とするらしいでございますあけてみましょう
ドンキで売ってるんですけどもこの鈍器で買えるもので嘘を見抜けるようだったら
世の中のウソを全部暴いてきてレベルなんですけど
うわぁなんかそれなりにそれっぽいこれが嘘半期です
くっ
吸盤もついているのは以下ちょっとやってみましょうか
びっくりスター頃さあ何か固定するのやな
スタートボタンを押します
音楽が何終わったら準備完了らしいで失望してはいかいいえを答えてもらってください
一人じゃできなくね自分で自分で質問します今日朝食べたご飯はカレーライスです
はいああああ
ああああああああ
あれ俺カレライス食ってねぇぞやっぱそうか自分で自分に質問したから良くないなら誰
かから質問されないとやっぱ正常な判断ができないかもしれません質問してもらいまし
たら自分でやってるとほんとになっちゃうんでお金は好きですか
いいえ
あほかね嫌いってこのか正しいなこれ
しっかりできてるならそれで僕がお金が好きじゃないっていうことは正面とは違う本当
に正しいかどうかっていうのは分からないんですよねあと今回うさ天気をたくさん準備
しました
これによってこれが正しかったんですけどもこんな嘘発見器が正しいかどうかってのは
分からないので
者から嘘パスでっていうかもしれないし本当に正しいかもしれない
のウソ発見器が本当にちゃんとしてるのかどうかをちょっと色んなファッキン気を使っ
て高めていこうと思います
市梅香予定た嘘発見器を開けていきましょう
よし
のんぐ今えっ ana
はいというわけで合計10個のウソ発見っていう準備しました
で今回等検証していくかといいますとちょっと今から一つの質問をしてもらいますその
質問に僕は答えませそれが嘘だったら電撃が流れるんですよ同じ質問を10回こうやっ
てくれ返して1個ずつやって言ってこれがことに c 駆け出す発券機だったら10回
ともちゃんと電力の中で前例が同じかだったら
正確な人発見器とダメだったら
[音楽]
低感じのばかりやすい懸賞になっておりますではやっていきましょう
えっ
ではいきますまず1個目ふう者数
課金さんの時良いですか
いいえ ana
ani
なんだなんだ
普段ひろ姉役だろに家へ行っただったり嘘ってことですね
好きなのにで今なら正しければ
いや正しくても嫌なんですけどよ新しければしびれデシベルシビル全部しびれていくと
思いますがそんなことないはずだ
ちょっと多数決だこれを張っていうかそれが見込めいきます金さんのことが嫌いですか
いいえ
それだ1味が強違うんだけど課金さんのことが嫌いですかいいえ
a
お嫁のこと好きですよ
ああああああ
入ってればいいんだでくれとか違和感のようなんねそんな気のある経過金さんのこと
わけないですか
いいえ
web のことスキでしょ
沸かせてください
好きれちゃうな
このこのほどこれはポロポロポロもらう2つ正しい答えですねどんどん行きましょう
た金さんのことが嫌いですかいいえあああああだいいえ
あああああいいいいえええええええいいえ
おとど cea
ああああああああ
いいえほら姉が金さんのことが嫌いですかいいえ
web ぬピーキス
んぞキラー
[音楽]
me
uh